más tarde que otras grandes economías
globales y con los juegos olímpicos en
el punto de mira japón comenzó la
vacunación contra el cob y 19 el
miércoles las autoridades comenzaron a
distribuir el suero de las farmacéuticas
facer by un tec entre el personal de
salud
tokio aprobar su primera vacuna el
domingo después de hacer varios ensayos
clínicos en el país para corroborar su
eficacia esto es un primer paso grande y
esperanzadoras y al final de esta nueva
pandemia de coronavirus
hay unos 100 centros médicos
administrados por el ministerio de
sanidad y tenemos previsto vacunar
primero a unos 40 mil trabajadores
médicos
las autoridades se enfrentan una gran
reticencia a las vacunas por parte de
los japoneses que temen los
relativamente raros efectos secundarios
otro de los desafíos es lograr la
inmunidad de rebaño a cinco meses de la
celebración de los juegos olímpicos
rechazados por el 80% de los ciudadanos
por el miedo al virus pero que suponen
un gran impulso a la economía del país
asiático
con respecto al relevo de la antorcha de
los juegos olímpicos de toque en nuestra
prefectura es posible que no tengamos
otra opción que tomar la decisión de
cancelarlo la situación actual continúa
así que me gustaría decirles que estamos
considerando una cancelación
tanto al gobierno japonés como el comité
organizador vacilan sobre el relevo de
la antorcha olímpica que comenzaría en
fukushima el 25 de marzo y recorrería el
país durante 121 días